[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis weiß
heute werde ich euch zeigen wie man
obatzda selber macht und zwar ist es so
eine käsecreme und ganz typisch
eigentlich für die bayerische küche gab
ja jetzt haben wir gerade oktoberfest
woche also müssen wir das unbedingt
zeigen
dazu gibt's laugen brötchen also laut
noten habe ich gemacht 23 brezeln habe
ich geformt und ja das ist wirklich
super einfach super lecker und wir
fangen jetzt zuerst einmal mit dem
laugengebäck und dafür zeige ich euch
hier nochmal die zutaten für den teig
brauche ich 150 milliliter lauwarmes
wasser einen halben würfel hefe das in
21 gramm ein teelöffel zucker eineinhalb
teelöffel salz 150 milliliter milch 40
gramm butter und 600 gramm mehl
ich sehe jetzt zuerst einmal das
lauwarme wasser und geht es dir eine
rührschüssel da kann ich jetzt die hefe
darin auflösen und gebe auch direkt den
zucker mit dazu und jetzt kommen auch
direkt die restlichen zutaten mit rein
also die milch mehl dass man eben nicht
so gut gesehen hat und auch gleich die
butter und jetzt kann ich den teig für
etwa fünf bis sieben minuten zu einem
geschmeidigen teig verkneten
und das könnte jetzt entweder so wie ich
mit einer küchenmaschine machen oder
auch ganz einfach mit der hand
[Musik]
der hefeteig ist jetzt verknetet jetzt
versprühe ich meine arbeitsfläche mit
etwas back trend spray und kann den
jetzt hier drauf zu einer kugel rollen
wenn er ein bisschen zu weich ist könnte
einfach ein bisschen mehl dazugeben
aber lasst ihn auf jeden fall erst
einmal sieben minuten durch kneten dann
weiß man nämlich wie konsistenz ist da
hatte ich gesungen
[Musik]
wenn ihr dann eine kugel geformt habt
dann könnt ihr auch die schüssel fetten
die kugel reinlegen
den teig abdecken und dann für eine
stunde ruhen lassen
[Musik]
derzeit ist jetzt schon aufgegangen und
jetzt habe ich hier ein bisschen mehl
auf eine arbeitsfläche und nehmen den
heraus jetzt könnt ihr einfach
entscheiden wie groß er die knoten
machen möchte
ich nehme jetzt immer 80 gramm portionen
[Musik]
um mit darauf knoten zu formen werden
zuerst einmal lange strenge geformt
daher braucht er jetzt die teiglinge
auch nicht zu kugeln formen vorher
hallo ok dann in der mitte zusammenlegen
und jetzt wehrbergen und jetzt wird
daraus ein knoten gemacht und die kommen
dann einfach auf ein backblech
ihr könnt aber auch zum beispiel kleine
bretz und formen dafür nimmt ihr das
stück
normalerweise sind aber brezeln 90 gramm
schwer also zehn gramm fehlen wird dann
wird's lang geformt
in der mitte bleibt schön dick das ist
dann die weiche stelle dann hinlegen und
zweimal zwiebeln und dann hier unten
fest drücken
[Musik]
käfig noten die durften jetzt für etwa
eine halbe stunde abgedeckt hohen daher
sind sie jetzt auch schön aufgegangen
jetzt kann ich die lage vorbereiten
dafür habe ich bereits zwei liter wasser
in einen großen topf gegeben
da gebe ich jetzt 100 granaten dazu ihr
könnt auch mit einer richtigen auge
arbeiten aus der apotheke oder aus der
bäckerei aber wenn man damit arbeitet
muss man sehr vorsichtig sein denn es
darf die haut die augen und die
arbeitsoberfläche nicht berühren daher
nehme ich lieber den kreisrat rom das
ganze lasse ich jetzt kurz aufkochen
jetzt kocht das wasser jetzt kann ich
den hut herunter stellen damit einfach
nur noch ein bisschen zimmert und jetzt
ganz vorsichtig arbeiten jetzt nämlich
mit einer schöpfkelle oder mit einem
schaumlöffel oder so wie ich mit einem
pfannenwender die teilchen vorsichtig
hoch tauchte jetzt kurz ein unterseite
dann auch nach oben drehen
für ein paar sekunden einfach drin
schwimmen lassen und dann kommen die
teile wieder heraus und dann setze ich
sie auf ein backblech
[Musik]
und wenn ihr möchtet nimmt jetzt einfach
noch so bis meersalz und können die
teilchen noch ein bisschen damit
bestreuen
[Musik]
und so kommen sie jetzt in den
vorgeheizten backofen bei 200 grad ober
unterhitze für etwa 15 minuten
[Musik]
so die erste portion ist jetzt schon
fertig die nehme ich jetzt direkt aus
dem backofen heraus und damit sie einen
schönen glanz bekommen werde ich sie
einfach noch mit back trends besprühen
alternativ könnt ihr sie einfach mit
flüssiger butter bestreichen und während
ich die jetzt noch ein bisschen abkühlen
lassen
ich stelle sie kurz zur seite zeige ich
euch hier vorne schon mal die zutaten
für das obazda dafür brauche ich 400
gramm camembert da ist vollreif das ist
ein bayerischer camembert sechs
esslöffel weiche butter vier teelöffel
paprikapulver einen teelöffel
kreuzkümmel ich habe ich noch zwei
zwiebeln diesen bereits geschält und den
teufel geschnitten salz und pfeffer so
jetzt bin ich ein bissl überfordert ich
weiß nicht ob es der oder das obertor
schlecker die käsespezialität jetzt
nehme ich den käse der linke wissen also
guter käse riecht ja immer ganz gut und
er sollte jetzt zimmer warm sein dass
ich hab den jetzt einfach ein bisschen
draußen stehen lassen und kann den jetzt
mit der gabel zerdrücken und daher ist
es jetzt auch ganz wichtig dass die
butterweiche ist denn die wird einfach
mit eingearbeitet
bei manchen rezepten ist auch ganz
üblich dass diese frischkäse oder ein
schuss milch mit rein kommt damit der
der obazda einfach wissen streichfähige
wird und er wird dann auch ein bisschen
leichter im geschmack so ist es im
prinzip ja ich glaube das original nur
mit butter und käse das andere war ein
bisschen die leichtere variante
[Musik]
tablets übrigens wegen kartoffelstampf
verkennung mit dem geht es ein bisserl
einfacher
jetzt kommen da die zwiebelwürfel rein
und auch die gewürze noch bisschen salz
und pfeffer und dann wird alles schön
durch gericht
[Musik]
jetzt ist der oberarzt fertig jetzt kann
ich ihnen umfüllen abdecken und dann
etwa zwei stunden im kühlschrank ziehen
lassen und dann darf der murat gleich
probieren
ich habe schon abgeschmeckt und man
schmeckt sehr lecker
[Musik]
so murat ich habe das jetzt hier für
dich angerichtet einfach mit so einem
ice portionierer und eigentlich ist es
auch das perfekte rezept für dich als
schwabe warum denn oberster stammt
ursprünglich daher man hat früher halt
alter käsesorten die im prinzip schon
überreif waren einfach vermischt mit der
business butter hat man nämlich nicht
gemerkt auf der käse schon überreif war
hatte diese gewürze mit rein und so hat
sich praktisch den rechtswegen wird von
einer hatte sowas einfach das team vor
die haustür zu spielen aber die
schwiegen das haus kommen wahrscheinlich
war das so der zweite nutzen aber
erstens war wie gesagt die
resteverwertung und durch die ganzen
gewürze merkt man das eben nicht jetzt
wo wir doch mal war ich geb dir noch
eine gabe ist der ausgleich doch in
termin auf der baustelle jetzt die frage
die handwerker sie schon das auto nach
liebe ich habe vor allem warum sich so
dunkel ist die augen
genau das ist halt weil es eben die aus
natron gemacht ist und nicht die vier
prozent glaube aus der apotheke aber
trotzdem also die brötchen es immer
super lecker und kann ich jetzt zugeben
dass unser käse auch über reif war und
ich denke es klappt es manchmal noch
fehlt das noch einmal machst du da ist
immer drin falschen mittelmeers mehr ja
aber was ich vergessen wie ich wollte
kümmel noch drüberstreuen im ganzen mit
olivia wieder hessische hand gießt denn
mag schon so gerne handkuss hessisch es
ist ja ok ja ich habe ganz vergessen man
kann noch kümmel im ganzen drüberstreuen
ich mag es persönlich nicht so sehr auf
kümmel herum zu beißen aber morath und
lebt zum beispiel auch kümmel brötchen
ja da sagt was kümmert mich also der
schmeckt gut
gut sehr gut dann hoffe ich dass ihr
euch dieses rezept auch gut schmeckt und
wünsche euch ganz viel spaß beim
nachmachen und wir sehen uns dann doch
nicht normal bis dann tschüss
haben wir zum saugen gebäck gesagt ich
mich erst auf super schön war ich gern
super die konsistenz sehr sehr schlimm
aber ich glaube jetzt auch ein stück ich
muss ja nicht mehr auf die baustelle
hier sind meine augen und dann gucken
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich kann
dies erspart